okay good evening members and officers
of the council and not forgetting
members of the press in public I welcome
you to this meeting of the council
Thursday the 12th of July 2018
housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs either through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the 4a please do not use the lifts
please assemble in Hawley square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber the Proceedings of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured
I urge anyone that filming proceedings
to avoid filming members of the public
particularly if they are children press
at present
does anyone intend for me in the meeting
this evening thank you any member
therefore in the public gallery who
objects to the possibility of being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
public from the meeting would everyone
pleasant please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
so we now move on to the formal agendas
and agenda item 1 is apologies for
absence I have one apology in advance so
let's councillor Wells and we have
received subsequent apologies from
councillor Larkins and Hillman are there
any other apologies councillor Piper
Thank You chair councillor
zeki is away on holiday Thank You
general item two minutes of the previous
meeting held on the 10th of May 2018 I
move that the minutes of the annual
meeting of the council held on the 10th
of May 2018 be approved and signed as a
correct record with the vice chairman
please second second at you thank you do
members agree thank you agenda item
three announcements and at this point
I'm going to ask for appreciation
eventually and this is a presentation of
the past Chairman's badge would
councillor Falcon please make her way to
the top of the table
well rehearsed and well-planned we're
going to find the bed would you like to
make your speech now depends on the
quality of the speech well I did thank
everybody for their support but I would
just like to reiterate that it was a
great privilege to represent the family
everywhere we went and to thank all the
officers and everybody concerned for the
advice and the support that they quite
willingly and freely gave and it was a
great experience and thank you very much
[Applause]
can I just add whilst we find the badge
that the position involves a lot more
than sitting at this point this podium
pontificating on occasions it does
require some dedication it does
interfere I know from personal
experience with your planned social life
you are on public scrutiny every time
you wear this badge and you attend civic
ceremonies all over the county and I
know from comets that I've received
since I took appointment that councilor
Falcon did a superb job thank you
you shouldn't have said that right give
me you're not coming around any Sunday
afternoons in the future it gives me
great pleasure to present you with the
past Chairman's badge I am sure members
would join me in thanking you for your
work presenting the council and
representing the council rather as
chairman so if members would like to
stand I can then present the past
Chairman's badge thank you and back to
the agenda and agenda item 4 is
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest this evening
councillor Campbell
I think agenda item 30 will capture
resolve wouldn't it thank you cheering
yes so there is a standard dispensation
in place for consideration of members
allowances thank you
general item five petitions one petition
has been received in accordance with
council procedure number 12 and he
petition containing 36 valid signatures
has been received by the council I am
therefore pleased to welcome miss Clark
to the meeting could you please make
your way to the top table miss Clark if
she's not here then I can't offer her
three minutes to introduce the agenda so
therefore I simply say in accordance
with the council's petition scheme the
petition will be referred to cabinet
without debate for a report to the
council within three ordinary meetings
thank you
agenda item six questions from the press
and public to questions have been
received from members of the public in
accordance with council procedure number
13 please note that only the questioner
and respondent are permitted to speak on
the question and that if the questioner
is not present at the meeting their
question cannot be put but will be
replied to in writing but the questioner
please only state the name of the
cabinet member to whom their question is
to be put and to read out the exact
wording of the question that they have
submitted to the council general item 6a
question number one from a member of the
public regarding clinical waste I'm
pleased to welcome mr. Norwood to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the top table
okay this question is for councillor
Taylor Smith could you please tell me
why the clinical waste collection has
deteriorated collections that used to
take two weeks now take three to six the
explanation I was given that it was due
to an increased number of users seems
barely credible Thank You mr. Norwood I
call upon councillor Taylor Smith to
respond Thank You mr. chairman thank you
for your question mr. Norwood
I should first like to reassure you that
there has been no general deterioration
of fanuc District Council's overall
clinical waste service we currently have
over 4,000 registered users who
regularly use our clinical waste
collection service but we have seen a
significant increase in requests for
shops collections recently as a result
of this increase in demand some users
have had to wait a little longer for
sharps box removals as all of these Box
removals have to be collected in a
controlled way across the district
council area and this collection service
is programmed on specific days as you
probably know I can now confirm that the
sharps clinical waste collection service
is caught up with a slight delay and we
are now taking bookings for one week in
advance which is the normal service
delivery time mr. Norwood please let me
reassure you and all other clinical
waste service users that fanuc District
Council is committed to maintaining
customer satisfaction for this very
important service if in future demand
for this service Rises we actually do
have enough capacity and flexibility to
add an extra collection day if necessary
and for your information we're currently
carrying out a benchmarking exercise
looking at other authorities around the
country and are going to be reviewing
the options that we have been finding
out about so there will be more
information to come in the future thank
you Thank You councillor Taylor Smith
and Thank You mr. Norwood
agenda item 6b question number 2 from a
member of the public regarding the local
plan would members please refer to
supplementary agenda number 1 I'm
pleased to welcome mr. r8 to the meeting
could you please make your way to the
top table
good evening my question is for
councilor Bob Byford the leader of the
council please could you outline the
potential risks satanic taxpayers if the
local plan is found a found unsound
thank you
Thank You mr. rate I call upon the
leader to respond yeah Thank You
chairman Thank You mr. right for your
question
if the local plan was to be found not
sound then that would actually create
delay in producing a local player and a
significant delay could result in
further intervention by the minister the
cost of any external work resulting from
intervention would have to be borne by
the council even if there were no
intervention there would still be
significant cost of the council in
reviewing and updating the evidence base
this could quite easily cost several
tens of thousands of pounds all the time
there is no adopted local plan there is
a significant risk that the council
cannot demonstrate a five-year housing
land supply if this occurs the council
would lose the ability to refuse housing
applications in undesirable locations or
could face an increased risk of losing
planning appeals and consequently a
greater risk of costs being granted
against the council is also likely that
the council would have to plan for the
higher number of homes expected under
the government's new housing methodology
and with less lost control over new
development there's a greater risk that
development will take place on more
unplanned basis Ally to this there is a
significant risk to the provision of key
infrastructures to support development
Road schools health facilities etc also
new policies related to local green
space energy and water efficiency and
internal space plan standards could not
be applied thank you thank you leader
and Thank You mr. rate
agenda item seven questions from members
of the council one question has been
received from members so agenda item 7a
question number one from a member
regarding housing with members please
refer to supplementary agenda number one
I call upon councillor Constantine
thank you very much chair can I just
preface breakfast this question by
reminding the chamber that currently in
the UK there are 4.1 million children
living in poverty and that since 2010
progress on social mobility has gone
into reverse you will recall that Thanet
has the highest child poverty rates in
Kent and in the southeast and that's
what drives this question so my question
which is two counts a Leslie game can
you tell me how the Conservatives are
planning to manage our current housing
crisis how many families with children
are impacted by the need to move into
temporary accommodation what is the what
are you planning to do to curb and
manage the costs associated with
providing temporary accommodation for
these families and children Thank You
council on Steiner members will note
that that was originally meant for the
leader but with consent it is now going
to be responded by the portfolio holder
so I now call upon council game to
respond Thank You chair Thank You
council constant times your question
homelessness is a national crisis not
just a crisis in sanik a national crisis
the Local Government Association have
reported that there are a hundred and
twenty thousand five hundred and forty
children living in temporary
accommodation with their families that
has been provided by local authorities
throughout the country this represents a
37 percent increase since 2014 this
crisis has been driven by a severe
shortage of affordable homes to rent and
the increasing cost of the private
rented sector research published by the
Joseph Rowntree Foundation in 2017
show that 3.4 million house households
40% of renters in England are spending
more than a third of income on their
rent this has risen from 32 percent 2.7
million households in 2005 stroke 6 year
ended the introduction of the homeless
reduction act in 2017 does refocus the
work of local councils on homelessness
prevention but when not in itself
resolve the shortage of suitable
affordable accommodation the national
picture this national picture is
reflected locally the council currently
as at Monday 9th of July 2018 has 168
households placed in temporary
accommodation we have been working hard
to ensure that households in temporary
accommodation are moved on as quickly as
possible and to improve the quality of
temporary accommodation provided this
represents a slight reduction from the
position at the beginning of the year
and further reductions are projected for
the remainder of the year of this number
71 households are families with children
all of whom have self-contained
accommodation including 11 families in
council-owned flats or houses there are
currently no families with children in
temporary hotel accommodation overall
the councillors use of hotel
accommodation has significantly reduced
since January down from 51 households at
the start of the year to 26 households
by the 30th of June the council
continues to invest in building new
homes investing 13 billion to deliver
150 new homes by 2020 we expect to
complete 20 homes during the current
financial year and construction is
progressing well with the first further
49 homes due to start over the same
period
we have additionally set aside 1.6
million for new temporary accommodation
to help reduce the overall cost of
homelessness to the council and are
currently looking for a suitable site to
develop since the implementation of the
homelessness reduction act
excuse me on 3rd of April the council
has supported 187 households with a
personal housing plan and successfully
prevented 92 households from becoming
homeless in the first place we have
enhanced our housing options team to
provide these services and improve the
effectiveness of homeless and
homelessness prevention we have set
aside funding in the current year for
homelessness and have launched a new
incentive scheme the landlord incentive
scheme to encourage private sector
landlords to make homes available for
households in need since April we have
provided financial assistance to 42
households to help them access a private
sector home this that the work sorry the
work that has been completed to prevent
homelessness construct new homes and
support people living in temporary
accommodation has both improved the
outcomes for homeless people and reduce
the cost of homelessness for the council
Thank You councillor gain counselor
Constantine do you have a supplementary
question I do Thank You chair and I'm
glad to hear this some progress but
however you say the situation is
improving and yet the cost of providing
temporary accommodation has climbed very
steep curve since 2010 from about 50,000
pounds to now about 1.2 million pounds
so that would kind of indicate that we
we do indeed have a crisis a crisis I
think 71 households with children
homeless in Thanet is 71 families with
children too many frankly and I'm
getting to it
I've got it I've got a question I'm
getting to it
should I do it now thanks please can you
comment on whether you think it's
actually time to look again at the local
plan using the matter of the urgent need
for social homes of which Stonehill park
of promise 400 plus as the key
imperative I believe this is what our
residents want and I believe that's our
job as councillors
Thank You counsel console fine not
exactly a question preamble but I'm
quite lenient on those things would you
like to respond counselor game thank you
the the issue at the local plan is
something that is still being worked on
as you know what I would like to suggest
to you actually is we are all aware that
homelessness is a great issue and I'd
like to arrange a meeting for you to
come and meet the head of the head of
housing and the housing options manager
so we can talk through ideas and see
what we can all do to help this
situation Thank You councillor game
agenda item 8 motions have noticed no
motions on notice had been received in
accordance with counts or procedure rule
3 so we can move swiftly on to agenda
item 9 leaders report I call upon the
leader
thanks chairman my latest report is a
factual account of things that have
happened or being announced since my
last report which in this case was April
well and I've been asked to acknowledge
that some of the things that get
reported in this are in fact as a result
of initiatives begun by the previous
Youth administration and I'm happy to do
that but equally I must point out that
most of the issues we're presently
addressing predate this administration
coming in and I've spoken before of this
administration's intention to continue
to use its enforcement powers to create
a better environment as part of a
clampdown planet District Council issued
1071 fixed penalty notices for littering
spitting and dog fouling offenses in the
six months to my these F P ends were a
sign of the council's zero-tolerance
approach we're also determined to push
for further penalties in the event of
non-payment of the fixed penalties as
such a country magistrate's court on the
1st of May 13 defendants were ordered to
pay a total of 4518 pound for littering
offenses and in the past two months
three Thanet residents were successfully
prosecuted for fly-tipping
by taking these court actions this
council continues to demonstrate that it
will not tolerate for
Tipene or the dropping of litter and
will pursue anyone who flouts the law
I can also announce that we will shortly
be launching a new anti-litter campaign
working in partnership with local people
where the focus will be on taking a
harder line that those that blight our
district in recent weeks we've seen a
successful prosecution of six rogue
landlords for housing related offences
this resulted in over 32,000 pounds in
fines sending out a clear message that
we will not tolerate landlords who
operate unsafe and illegal properties
making tenants life a misery in June TDC
raised awareness of the alcohol control
public space protection order by
targeting alcohol-related anti-social
behavior this led to 24 formal warnings
being given 29 people surrendered
alcohol to officers six young people
were dealt with under different powers
and one fixed penalty notice was served
we've also opened our new
state-of-the-art CCTV control room the
whole network of cameras are now
high-definition with images being sent
via Wi-Fi resulting in excellent quality
helping to keep the area safer and
giving a better chance of catching
defenders I'm also pleased to report the
start of a program of investment in
smart bins to improve our service these
indicate we're now are nearly full so
they can be emptied before they become
full thus avoiding the problem of
overflowing and a resultant mess that's
caused as far as asset management is
concerned I'm pleased to note that we've
successfully sold the fault Road Hotel
at auction for 360,000 pounds the
building has had a checkered history
since we acquired it and I look forward
to seeing new owners plans for the
building cabinet on the 14th of June
approved a number of disposals including
the transfer of Burton memorial ground
and land at alpha road known as dog acre
to Burrington Parish Council thus
confirming our intention to work more
closely with town and parish councils in
a move that will ensure local control of
these assets for the benefit of the
local community cabinet also approved
the transfer of the old look out of
Broadstairs to community management thus
securing the future of this important
asset in other property matters it's
also good to see
on the ground at the pleasure armasight
whilst at the moment this is limited to
site clearance and tidying it does show
progress by the new owners in restarting
the development on this prime site last
week I had the privilege to be at the
dreamland for the unveiling by Margate
estates of their plans for an exciting
new hotel on Margate seafront which is
further testament to the town's
resurgence attracting visitors from far
and wide and indeed across the district
we've seen a 19 percent increase in our
visitor economy and there is evidence of
unfulfilled demand for additional bed
space for those now looking to extend
this day is infinite the winter shelter
statistics were published in May this
follows its successful second year of
operation it was found that there were
16 fewer people living on our streets
and 35 vulnerable people were supported
over the winter months of these 25 are
now being helped to a life off the
streets
33 received medical consultations 12 had
structured mental health assessments 3
in training and to have actually found
employment and that's a tremendous
outcome and huge thanks to due to the
hundred and seven volunteers who donated
a staggering four thousand five hundred
and sixty hours to the projects against
this backdrop it is welcome news that
the government has announced its
intention to half a number of rough
sleepers by 2022 and to eliminate the
problem completely by 2027 as a first
step they are making 30 million pounds
of funding available to start tackling
the issue then at councillors housing
departments submitted a bid for three
hundred and eighty nine thousand for
projects to reduce rough sleeping and
I'm very pleased to report were
allocated three hundred and sixty seven
thousand follow another recent awards
I'm also pleased to report that the
housing team achieved highly commended
for two of our shortlisted entries as
part of the 2018 national municipal
journal Awards I feel at this time it's
probably important to update members on
the situation regarding travellers Kent
as a whole has seen an increase in the
number of travel incursions over the
last 12 months and this has been
reflected in the numbers we have seen in
Thanet it's important to remember that
gypsies in
travelers are protected from
discrimination by the Equality Act 2010
which means they cannot and should not
be persecuted just because of their
lifestyle culture or origin however that
does not mean they can break the law and
thus such TDC has taken action against a
number of incursions including wearing
appropriate moving them from council
land
I appreciate there's been some
frustration expressed by the public but
the council has to follow the proper
process in dealing with incursions and
this takes time it doesn't mean the
council is not being effective or not
taking the matter seriously we are
looking for solutions to make
unauthorized access to land at Jacquie
Baker's more difficult and whilst our
worker welcomed the ideas that some
members of the community have put
forward the council is required to go
through formal processes so it's not
just as straightforward as digging the
ditch or putting up a fence
we are currently undertaking the process
of assessing a number of options and I
will informed local residents once we
have decided on the most suitable course
of action and I expect that announcement
to be very soon on the 30th of April a
new website was launched and has already
seen 82,000 visits feedback has been
positive and when tested by the Society
of Information Technology Management for
usability and ease of finding
information they gave it their maximum
rating of 4 stars not only that we've
been listed as one of their recommended
websites for best practice I think
that's a first for fanuc with with
regard to the Thames Estuary 2050 growth
commission TDC contributed to a call for
ideas back in September 2016 since when
the Commission has been reviewing over a
thousand contributions it received it's
now launched its conclusions in its 2050
vision by 2050 xx the Thames Estuary
will be a tapestry of productive places
along a global River the estuary will
create 1.3 million new jobs and generate
a hundred and ninety billion of
additional GBA and at least 1 million G
I looked up what GV I meant earlier and
I've forgotten our gross value added
I'm sure you were all desperate to know
that GVR stands for gross evaluate its
going to add 190 billion pounds worth of
that okay and at least 1 million new
homes will be delivered the report
identifies key areas along the River
Thames from London to Fannett and south
end planet along with Canterbury Swan
and Midway will be part of the North
Kent foreshore where proposals include
establishment establishing a North Kent
for short fund the improvement of
education attainment and skills
acquisition thus creating clear pathways
to employment and the creation of a
health super center TDC is currently
considering the detailed content of the
report with a view and how it might want
to engage and contribute to these
proposals it was announced in May that
the 2019 Turner prize will be hosted by
Turner contemporary and TDC are already
working with Turner contemporary and
early discussions about how we can all
make the most of the opportunities
they're hosting the Turner Prize will
bring it's expected that between
September and December 2019 there will
be an additional three hundred thousand
visitors to the exhibitory the
exhibition of the work of the
shortlisted artists this will further
raise mark Margaret's profile both
nationally and internationally it is
really a highly prestigious
international award and it's really good
that is coming to town finally as part
of their member training and development
programme democratic services are
starting a process of encouraging more
candidates to stand as councillors in
2019 this will involve public sessions
of the council and further outreach
sessions so that we can explain the role
of a counsellor what training develop
and new counsellors can expect what
allowances are provided particularly for
those with caring responsibilities and
the support and help they would get from
the Democratic support saying I believe
that this is a welcomed initiative which
may lead people coming forward who might
otherwise been afraid of the unknown and
we all know they should be afraid very
afraid
Thank You leader in the absence of
councillor Wells I call upon counsel in
Fairbrass to comment on or ask questions
in relationship to the leaders report
counselor therapist Thank You chairman
I'd like to thank councillor Beaufort
for his reports us evening and his
acknowledgement within of his
inheritance of successful actions and
projects from the UK administration that
preceded him he could have added the
relative financial stability of this
council to his list which was probably
the starkest difference in inheritance
between 2015 and 2018 however much of
what is has said is underpinned by a
common sense and good housekeeping
approach and that in itself is welcome
in looking after the longer-term
concerns and futures of our residents I
also like to note that he avoids all
mention of the local plan which
dominates all other issues at the moment
and avoids acknowledging much of the
simple good advice he Sutent heard from
members of the previous administration
just 24 hours ago
he needs now to ponder carefully what
local plan options come forward to
council because what is currently
proposed lacks the long term beneficial
common sense he seems to so admire in
other areas of this council's business
he has less than a year as leader to
prove he has the capacity to steer this
council prudently for the future or he
will be handing on the sort of mess we
inherited in 2015 because on the big
issues he cannot deliver reality over
unsubstantiated dream in 2014 this
council was branded toxic and
dysfunctional by peer review mainly
because councillors could not and would
not accept sound legal advice I hope and
trust councillor Beaufort is not leading
us back there on the big issues that
indeed would be troubling and damaging
when compared to his inheritance of an
award-winning and financially stable
organization I would always like also
like to mention and welcome the recent
decision to implement a new landlord
incentive scheme I know that the team
have been working on this for a very
long period of time in order to assist
alongside the help to move scheme the
growing number of household
facing homelessness infinite to secure
private rented accommodation thank you
Thank You councillor Fairbrass does the
leader wish to respond well I need to
thank Casa favor us for some of her
comments and just to really point out
that I thought the idea was to ask
questions about what I'd said and and to
comment but do didn't really seem to do
but well done all the same
thank you I call upon counts the
Reverend Piper to comment on or ask
questions in relationship to the leaders
report and I'm sure there's one or two
questions coming up accounts of Piper
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You leader
for your efforts particularly the time
you have actually spent communicating
with other groups about your activities
and your aspirations moving forward
notably communicating your efforts to
secure a local plan that the majority of
members can support next week remains to
be seen of course wherever the council
will support the proposal but no doubt
many are hopeful that the change is
being suggested and the departure from
the journey with the 18th draft will
show that the decision to vote that some
of us did that night was the right one
in the circumstances I would like to
join you in congratulating the housing
team on another fine recognition for
their work much of your report as you
say is factual and my time is short so I
hope you will not mind if I focus my
response on one particular key area of
concern
the recent traveler incursions have
shown gaping great big holes in our
preparedness and our capability of
prevention I am much more familiar with
the situation at Jackie Baker's than I
am with Dane Valley but I know that
councillor Gary Taylor shares many of
the same concerns I'd like to give
members some more details of the kind of
information that they may not otherwise
hear about regarding Jackie Baker's the
number of unlawful break-ins with
associated criminal damage is on the
rise the amount of rubbish including
human excrement and fly-tipping is
disgraceful recently they stole a full
gas
and even the door from a local fast food
outlet in Northwood and took it to
Jackie Baker's not only did they
dangerously leave the empty cylinder
behind but the original owner has
suffered considerable financial loss
many regulars residents are in regular
contact with me seeking firm responses
to definitive action to make this area
more secure leader I have had
conversations with and shared emails
with officers and the chief executive
officer came for a walk about the site
just a couple of weeks ago we have in
the last year being offered useful help
and advice from among others mr. Bruce
grant for the construction of a
significant fund and we have discussed
kissing gates to prevent incursions by
locals on motorbikes and all-terrain
vehicles the travelers plus these
recalcitrant locals are a blight on the
rest of the community and they simply
must be stopped many of the comments I
get later are that the rights and
privileges of the travelers seem to be
given far more attention than the rights
of residents sadly it isn't really too
difficult to see why people would come
to that conclusion it may not be right
but it's not too difficult to see how
they think that they might think that
leader there simply isn't enough effort
being made to stop these motorcycles
abusing the park many of the riders have
no registration plates and yet ride on
the public road to get to the park we
are concerned leaner and we would ask if
there can be more work done about the
lack of grass cutting because the seeds
on the type of grass that is growing on
Jackie Baker's is often dangerous to
dogs and I know of one resident whose
dog has died as a result of grass seed
complications please then can we have a
confirmation of serious action to be
taken to secure and regularly maintain
the area of Jackie bakers as you have
indicated in your report Thank You chair
leaders to respond yeah Thank You
chairman an accounts the property I mean
we talked about this I mean and
as I said in my report it is something
that we take very seriously I think this
year has been exceptional I've not been
aware of the number of incursions as
we've experienced this year and it does
seem as though in certain places some of
the behavior has been beyond the power
we understand that completely understand
that residence nearby are very upset
about it
I can only reassure you or hope to
reassure you that as I said in my report
we are looking at this I expect to come
forward with some proposals for Jackie
Baker's very soon and we are looking at
other think actions that we can take
what also point out as well of course
that a lot of the behaviors should be
reported to the police and it's then
there should be dealing with it as far
as the grass cutting is concerned I'll
take your clients back to the relevant
service thank you thank you leader
I call upon counts the matter phase to
comment on or ask questions in
relationship to the leaders report
councillor metaphase Thank You chair I'm
not mentioning the local plan you might
be pleased but I do have some points to
raise and I've got some questions for
the leader you said with their taking a
harder line with those who drop litter
does that include the bin men about whom
I get endless complaints because they
don't pick up after themselves I direct
that question to the gentleman sitting
behind you as well with regard to the
CCTV I'm glad this has been kept locally
and is now functioning as knowledge of
the local area is obviously crucial but
I would like to ask how many spots smart
bins have we actually got and where have
they been located please so I'll take it
or take a written answer later don't
worry we're ordinary bins if you got the
answer that's fine a live answer thank
you where ordinary beans are located
they need emptying more often this is
becoming an increasing problem we're
encouraging residents and visitors to
use them but it's very frustrating when
they aren't emptied often enough
especially in our public parks and
especially in my local parks and Peter's
recreation grove every day I get
complaints about the fact the bins
haven't been emptied people are using
them but unfortunately if they're only
emptied once or twice a week it is
insufficient could you please tell me
how many road sweepers with brooms we
now have because I get various speakers
I would like to know there is a reason
for asking the question by the way this
morning on Beacon Road I saw the mini
scarab shooting down there which was a
very very welcome sight but
unfortunately it is used on roads are so
parked up it just goes down the middle
at 30 miles an hour and doesn't pick up
anything at all we do need people out
there particularly in heavily parked up
roads people with brooms and litter
picks I've done umpteen litter picks and
I know other people do and we know it is
an increasing problem but we need some
kind of action maybe an education
program I don't know what the answer is
but we need to start doing something now
regard to winter shelter I was one of
the hundred and seven volunteers you've
just thanked and I've already signed up
for this year and I'm very glad that an
organizer is already in place this month
because last year there were a few admin
issues people who volunteered who were
not contacted so hopefully with the work
with the Salvation Army and with housing
we can make sure that that is covered I
think it's important to appreciate that
all those who are sleeping rough do have
a story to tell and we should realize
that any one point
anybody could become homeless one of the
things I learned in the winter shelter
was some of the stories which were
tragic some of them were just bad luck
some of them were done to drink some of
them down to drugs but everybody had a
story to tell and what does concern me
particularly is to see the number of
women who are now sleeping rough because
they are exceptionally vulnerable or
rough sleepers are vulnerable but women
are particularly vulnerable with regard
to the money it's great to hear that but
I hope it won't just be used for staff
because I hope some of it will filter
through to the various agencies that do
help rough sleepers like the gut project
so counselor before I would like to
invite you should join me on a Tuesday
afternoon at the gap project in
Broadstairs between 2:00 and 4:00 and
you will be able to meet the rough
sleepers the volunteers the staff and
agency workers there including
Porchlight
and turning-point the chief executive
and I had a very interesting afternoon
there and her visit was
much appreciated I'm also very concerned
has been raised by council a constant
time the number of families becoming
homeless
all of us have dealings with people
whose lives are just turned upside down
often through no fault of their own
many have employment here I've dealt
with people who said how am I going to
get to work if I moved to Midway I put
children's secondary school doing exams
and I think this is the family is
unstable enough I'm being moved out of
area creates even greater stability
instability when they have a journey to
make I know it uses up enormous amounts
of officer time and homelessness is a
threat to families because they become
extremely anxious they become worried
and the children are concerned about
their educational standards so I would
like to ask what's this is a question
what's being done to get for more
funding to increase the supply of social
housing and very pleased that in my ward
the houses that are being built are
almost completed and also like to say
that the contractor I've said this to
mr. Porter the contractor has engaged
with all the residents kept them fully
updated and what is happening I would
like you also possibly to investigate
the house and a box scheme our house can
be built in two to three weeks that have
cost 250 thousand pounds we have to
supply the land but there is funding and
it's like it's bit like a posh prefab if
those of us old enough to remember
prefabs can remember what they were like
I would also like to add my congrats
I've got two sentences to the excellent
housing team who are always helpful and
go definitely go above and beyond the
event for potential councillors is to be
very welcomed as it's cross-party and
it's using experienced counselors like
myself in addition to officers and the
members training group of which
councillor Taylor Smith and others
sitting here our members have done
sterling work in all that we've been
presented with and we have been aided by
democratic services whom I have to thank
for their patience and good-natured
approach and tolerance of when we ask
them really difficult questions thank
you thank you council matter face and I
can let you know that
councillor mayor Saunders and I met the
new lady road sweeper in Broadstairs
this morning and she
had a brush in her hand not a picker
leader to respond
yeah thanks Yemen Thank You councillor
masa face the hard fact questions that
you've asked I will get written answers
to for you you you raise the point of
winning rough sleepers as I understand
it and the national average is about 10
percent
Infinite's 25 percent they do have
special vulnerabilities and I'm sure
you'll be pleased to know they're part
of the money from government is going to
be spent on a hostel specifically for
women rough sleepers so nothing that's
quite good news I'm happy to accept your
offer to go to the gut project would we
do that and I've been a reliably
informed by my colleague to my left that
we are actually investigating the house
in a box game so we're ahead of you
there thank you
Thank You leader without that to the
other answers thank you a generalize
from ten changes committees panels and
boards for the year 2018 19 based on
proportionality with members please note
that there is a typographical error in
the table for option one at paragraph
two point nine of the report the table
should show that the labor group have
one member on the licensing board I call
upon the leader to make a proposal in
respect of the options as outlined in
the report leader proposed option one
chair is there a seconder council
Fairbrass does any member wish to
propose an alternative option
in that case can I ask do members agree
thank you nomination of members to serve
on committees group leaders may wish to
make this take this opportunity to
advise of changes to their nominations
to committees panels and boards for the
remainder of 2017 18 council baitha do
you wish to advise of any nomination
changes I think we were required to
nominate a new member for licensing and
that will be counselor bambridge I would
also like to take this opportunity to
nominate planning substitutes counts the
Maeve Saunders councillor Bainbridge
counts the dexter and counts the Taylor
Smith thank you thank you
calathea brass do you wish to advise of
any nomination changes
I have already advised the chair so
thank you and councillor Reverend Piper
Smith do you wish to advise of any
nomination changes Thank You chair the
seat we would lose on licensing would be
the seat that was held by the late Allen
house so the current licensing group for
our group would be canceled Linda pots
councillor Roy Potts and counsel John
Dennis and the other change to planning
we're going to ask council to Trevor
shank to step aside so our planning
members would be canceled John Buckley
councillor Robin Edwards and councillor
Gary Taylor mr. mr. chairman can I also
take this opportunity to inform council
that with the departure of councilor
Suzanne brim we as a group have
appointed councillor Robin Edwards to
sit as our opposition spokesperson for
operational services shadowing
councillor Terry Smith thank you jack
Thank You councillor Parker councillor
matter face we have no changes Thank You
chair thank you agenda item 11 changes
to the council's Constitution I move
that the recommendation as set out in
the report be adopted with the vice
chairman please second signature
do members agree one hands gone up
counselor Thank You chairman I've got a
question if I may
about the proposed report and the
Constitution under 5.2 it states that
the overview no sorry beg pardon
it states that overview screw tea and no
longer allowed to create working parties
I wondered why that was especially when
in 9.1 it talks about the constitutional
review working party Thank You counsel
messenger monitoring officer to respond
yes the reason for the reduction in
working parties is because the workload
has effectively increased by doubling
the number of panels and obviously the
staff hasn't changed so we have limited
capacity to manage those so instead of
having working parties the world will be
divided up between the two panels
instead thank you okay counselor thank
you agenda item 12 is calendar of
council meetings for 2018 19 I move that
the recommendation are set out in the
report be adopted with the vice chairman
please second second at yet do members
agree thank you
apologies for the rustling of paper
agenda item 13 members allowances scheme
2018-19 I call upon the leader remove
the recommendation is printed chair is
there a seconder
secondly chin do members agree Thank You
general item 14 nominations to
non-executive outside bodies once again
I call upon the leader
Thank You chair members can see the list
there are still a number of vacancies
and if there are any members who tonight
wish to volunteer to fill those
vacancies we could take them customers
face thank you flashing green at me I'd
like to nominate councillor Constantine
for the Fallot volunteer Bureau and the
youth advisory group please yeah happy
to take that any other nominations okay
in that case those two nominations and
the list is printed I so move chair
we had a seconder seconded sure you
members now agree thank you
agenda item 15 standards hearing
decision councillor brim I call upon the
monitoring officer Thank You chairman
rather sadly some extent this report
relates to a further breach of the
council's code of conduct but countless
as Ambrym the last breach from hurricane
to the council on the 22nd of February
this year less than five months ago and
you may recall the breach of the code
then related to a comment from Council
of brimm about the council officer on
her Facebook page that breach resulted
in a vote of censure from the council in
this latest case council brim published
an officer's ex directory personal
telephone number on facebook and invited
those reading her Facebook page to call
her I'm sure she'll be glad to hear from
you I read out in February and I
read again what the protocol a member
offers the relation says it says that
members should be aware the officers are
constrained in the response they may
make to public comments from members
members should not criticize officers
personally in public or through the
press nor seek to undermine their
position by abuse rudeness or ridicule
to continue to make public comments
about officers knowing that they are
constrained in their ability to apply is
in my view of monetary officer a
cowardly and despicable act it was an
immature thing to do and reflects poorly
on a counselor who's meant to be leading
a setting an example to her community
however causa bream says she thought she
was doing nothing wrong she showed no
remorse and she offered no apology
counselor bream was requested to remove
the offending comments but she did not
do so castle brim also showed a complete
disregard and lack of respect for the
standards process she refused to engage
in the complaints process she did not
engage with the investigator and nor did
she attend the final hearing counsel
brim was in any event found to be in
breach of the following provisions of
the code of conduct attempting to
intimidate an officer attempting to
bully an officer disclosing information
which was of a confidential nature and
bringing her office into disrepute causa
brims conduct reflects badly on the
reputation of the council generally and
also is very costly each investigation
costs the council about 4,000 pounds and
that doesn't include officer and member
time and the cost of investigations
indicates a trim this year amount to
some 8,000 pounds it doesn't need to be
this way complying with the council code
of conduct is not difficult I think it's
something that members achieve with very
little effort generally simply by
following the ordinary standards of
behavior which we all follow in our
daily lives
kasib rim on the other hand has great
difficulty in following these simple
rules attempts have been made to educate
council brim
she's been advised where's your fund
advice and how people should behave and
has been offered individual training
which she has refused as the council's
monetary officer I think the cats at
brim needs to think about her role as a
counselor and her inability to follow
these simple rules of conduct if she's
incapable of following these simple
rules I would ask her to seriously
consider whether she is suited to a role
in public life the independent person
appointed by the council who advises
members and the standards committee said
unfortunately councillor brim is only
too familiar with the limitations of
sanctions that are currently available
to the standards committee and the
officers of the council in the past the
committee have imposed sanctions on
causa brim advised her and offer
guidance and training
nothing has seen to change her opinions
or attitude if counts of Brynn won't
take notice of the standard committee
and change of behavior or take notice of
me as monetary officer and to alter her
behavior or take notice of her fellow
councilors when they pass the boat
essentia to modify her behavior I would
make a plea and make a Pete had she been
here a plea to Castle brim that could
she just please just take notice of the
phrase that she has right at the top of
her Facebook page where she says just be
nice to one another it's not difficult
if she followed her own advice she would
not be the subject of complaints and at
the same time would save the council a
substantial sum of money in the meantime
I invite council Council to Center
Council of brim for her behavior and
posting the private home telephone
number of a council officer on Facebook
thank you
I therefore propose of the council
censures councillor brim for her
behavior in post in the private home
telephone number of a council officer on
Facebook which resulted in councillor
prim breaching the following provisions
of the code of conduct and the
monitoring of officers already outlined
they are a
attempting to intimidate an officer be
attempting to bully an officer see
disclosing information which was of a
confidential nature and they bring in
her office in to distribute with the
vice chairman please second do members
agree councilor Hayden could you tell me
how long the counter brim has to be
bacon from this council meetings before
the six months is up and she has to be
banned from being a counselor after six
months thank you she has to attend a
meeting of which he is a member so last
night wouldn't have counted but I'm
because I haven't checked when you've
asked attended a meeting in her own
right but you're right he still is six
months it's more than six months for
that attending a meeting that she is
disqualified thank you any other
councillors wish to comment or debate
I've had agreement from all councilors
so let's thank you and that concludes
the business of this meeting of the
council I look forward to seeing you all
this time or 7:00 o'clock next Thursday
when I think we'll have an equally
interesting meeting thank you